هل تتذكرون عامل الاطلاع او النقاش المصري
الذي اسر القلوب على منصات التواصل بغنائه
لاغنيه الراحله ورده المطرب احمد سالم
الذي فتحت له الابواب بمقطع غنائي مصور
بالهاتف كان من المفترض ان يشارك مسرح دار
الاوبرا المصريه مع الفنانه اصاله ضمن حفل
ختامه رجانا الموسيقى العربيه لكن في
لحظات الاخيره يستبعد احمد من الغناء
وينشر فيديو يؤكد فيه ان استبعاده كان
سببه عدم استكمال الاوراق المطلوبه لكن
القصه تاخذ منحا اخر عندما وراء المناع
الموسيقى حلمي بكر رئيس اللجنه التحضيريه
لمهرجان الموسيقى العربيه والذي قال اين
تقاليد الغناء في الاوبرا وشروطها لا
تنطبق على المطرب النقاش
بخصوص الناس اللي داخله عندي على المنصات
بتقول لي يا احمد انت ليه ما طلعتش في
المهرجان مع الفنانه اصاله بما انك وضحت
الفيديو اللي انت نزلته بتاع البروفا
انا يا جماعه بعتذر منكم وباقول لكم انا
ما طلعتش لعدم استكمال اوراق كانت مطلوبه
مني المفروض ان انا اعملها
فانا الوقت ما حلتنيش لان الوقت كان ضيق
ومسؤوليه الاوبرا ان واحد لاول مره هيغني
لازم يكون مقدم موسيقيا وعامل برباط قاطع
ممكن يكون عمل برفات فله صح ان هو يطلع
لان ده محتاج كان يقهل قبل ما يطلع يغني
انا اول من استمع الى احمد سالم ومعجبته
وحسيت ان في طعم جديد في حياتنا بعد فوضى
اغاني المهرجان قلت ده هيكون بدايه جميله
جدا ان احنا نرجع لقصرنا الغنائيه خلاص
بعد كده في اللجنه التحضيريه حطينا برامج
اللي هي اعلن عنها طول البرنامج ولي للاسف
كان نفسي الاعلام يتكلم عن عن المهرجان من
اوله لاخره مش عن حاجه
احب اقول
ان لما اتحط اصاله لم تعلن اصاله ناسا
وبدو تشرق
الاستاذ احمد سالم
اداره المهرجان ما كانش عندها علم فجاه
الاداره المرجان لاقت بيتعمل بروفا فطلبت
منه بعض اوراق ويجي يتقابل على اساس يسجل
ويبقى ليه مكان داخل الاوبرا راح اختفى ما
جاش ثم فوج
اصاله حصل حوار ما بينها وما بين الاداره
المهرجان ان كذا طب اخبرينا طب قولي لنا
طب احنا قلنا له تعالى طب كل شيء قالت
طبعا هتصرف هذا التصرف نتج عنه انه ما
طلعش مش من اداره المهرجان ولكن صاحب
التصرف هو فضل انه يبتعد عن المشاكل او
انه اعتقد ان هناك في مشاكل فلم يحضر
الحفل
الثاني طارق الشناوي
مباشر مع السيد حلمي لكن كيف ترد عليه
[موسيقى]
الكبير ولا ولا يستطيع احد ان يقلل من
انجازه ولكن هو بيتناقد في اقواله
والصحافه نشرت انه قال هي اصاله عايزه
تعمل ترند وان هو منعها من الترند يقصد
بالترند ال- همم احمد سالم ان هي اعجابته
فبالتالي هو قال حتى انه لا لسه كل ده
قاله هو بس هو ساعات يتلقى 180 درجه انه
وقال هو لسه محتاج لتدريبات وعشان يطلع
على الاوبرا دلوقتي انا شايف بيتراجع فيه
او 80 درجه الصوت اللي هو قال عليه لا
محتاج لتدريبات
وبيبرق ساعه الجميع الحقيقه انه البروفات
تمت الاوبرا المصريه مش في بيت اصاله ولا
في ستوديو خاص هي تعمل له مش ممكن احد
يعمل بروفات في دار الاوبرا عريقه زي
الاوبرا المصريه هو من غير ما يبقى في
معروف مين ده او هيعمل ايه هو بيقول لم
يستكمل الاوراق او انه ما جاءش ده ده هو
منع زوم
الافتتاح يعني مثلا لو قلنا كان قصدي يوم
الغناء لو قلنا ان احنا البروفات كانت يوم
الاربعاء ف- ف- فالخميس منع طب ده هو
هيبقى اكثر واحد حريص
لانه خلص اوراقه مش انه يتعرب من ان هو
يقدم ان هم عايزين يقول عايزينه هيبقى
اسمه بتاعي يعني حاجات كده همم تفاصيل
يعني بسيطه واللي عايز اقوله كمان حاجه
مهمه في اي حفل في الدنيا بيحصل هو اولا
مش جاي يغني منفردا لا بيحصل فقره كده
بانه مثلا احد يطلع على المسرح موجود في
الصاله وده حصل حتى بالصدفه في حفله اصاله
انه في بنت طلعت واا حضنتها ممكن الاثنين
كانوا
وبعدين قالت لها انت بتحب الغناء قالت لها
اه انا باحب اغني وباغني لكن انت بتغني
يعني اصل انا طلبت منها ان تغني هل اخذت
اذن الاوبرا اكيد لا البنت بس كل الحكايه
همم اتكسفت فنزلت من على المسرح بعد ما
كان ممكن هي دي فقره يعني ايه في جزء كده
بيبقى مش شرط يبقى منظم 100% والرغم ذلك
الراجل
الاوبرا المصريه بس اللي انا شايفه انه
حلم يتراجع 180 درجه و كويس
همم بده يرد عليك نشكرك جزيل الشكر الناقد
الفني طارق الشناوي سيد حلمي هل تترغبت في
الرد على ما قاله طارق
الشناوي يعرف ان انا عمري ما بتراجع وقلت
ان انا اول من استمعت لي قبل منه انا سمعت
فيديو واشد به ولكن نظام الاوبرا لو عمل
بروبا في الاوبرا وفوقه اداره الاوبرا
بتتعمل بروفا من غير ما يكون عندها اقل
واساله اداره الاوبرا واسالوا اللجنه
التحضيريه فقالوا له ابني احنا موافقين طب
تعال قابلنا فيه في ميعاد يوم كذا
يدخله بقى يا استاذ طارق
[موسيقى]